and now he's switching switching focus
and he's oh hang on a second hang on i
was just going to say this wasn't
possible because i was thinking
oh
i'm too excited david i need you too oh
yeah look at the bar black has actually
blocked up this line now blocked up the
sea lion so white queen under fire from
that bishop and because the connection
between the white rooks has been broken
black is also threatening to capture one
of white's rooks with his own rook so a
double threat now for magnus carson and
i think you're right ivanka this is
gonna cost white material how are you
going to save the queen and your rook at
the same time you either have to give up
the queen for a couple of rooks but the
queen here is by far the most important
piece are we going to see it on the
board okay i was going to say maybe you
could sacrifice the root of a bishop as
well but now white queen has fallen
white's gained two rooks in the process
but look at the white king without the
white queen how are you going to defend
it that king looks so
it's horrible i mean first of all you
know white would really love to put the
rooks on the top rope they can't do that
because queen takes porn is now in the
air and now the queen and the bishop
have coordinated for an attack on the g
for pawn and this is it when it comes to
peace positions with peace imbalances is
all about king safety and white king i'm
sorry it's got no cover it's doomed yeah
look at that evaluation it confirms your
assessment completely there your anchor
white king i mean it would love a night
around it would love a queen around to
defend but no those pieces don't exist
and now all that black needs to do is
move his bishop and on this g-line it's
disaster it's actually checkmate in a
few moves now black's bishop coming to
attack that white bishop which is pinned
and checkmate comes
i'll tell you resigns wow what a start
to the final you guys